fear on the island of la palma an
unstoppable torrent of lava destroying
everything in its path and altering the
landscape now flowing into the atlantic
plumes of toxic gases below above the
fishing village of tazakorte its mayor
is getting ready to evacuate
there are no words to express what i
think or feel there's no way for us to
anticipate how this disaster will unfold
authorities have set up a three and a
half kilometer cordon around the cumbre
vieja volcano the thermal shock of
molten rock entering the ocean is
producing a cloud composed of sulfur
dioxide and acid lava
in some area the ocean has turned gray
and murky it's not just toxic chemicals
that are being released but also
minerals scientists believe that in the
long run this will make marine life even
richer and more diverse in this disaster
they see an opportunity to better
understand volcanic eruptions so as to
anticipate what [ __ ] riviera will do next
volcanologists are recording increased
seismic activity on the southern flank
of the volcano
that suggests that pressure on the
crater is increasing as powerful magma
from below the earth breaks through the
surface i cannot predict it
what i can tell you is that this
eruption
this is i can't predict this this
eruption is going to continue
the same way we've seen so there will be
periods of activity
higher intensity lower intensity as we
saw yesterday some
proposed periods
and until eventually
it may last weeks or months we don't
know but what i can tell you i'm pretty
is that the
behavior is going to continue the same
more of the same means more destruction
close to 7 000 people are displaced in
more than 500 homes buildings and
churches charred to ashes and the lava
is widening its reach as it closes in on
tasakorte
nicholas hawk al jazeera tazacorte spain
la palma